knowing what to do is not the same as
knowing how to do it so the first
question what do you do to lower
surgical deaths now we knew how use a
checklist much as they do in aviation
how do you get people to use a checklist
was another puzzle and over the years
what we found is it's a combination of
really needing you can't just pay them
or create a regulation that says you
have to do it you have to recognize as a
culture change and walk people hand in
hand through a hospital process a team
process where they can get everybody on
board with making a very complex change
even though it seems like a simple two
minute checklist shouldn't be so
complicated so it's really about culture
change not not just ticking off the
boxes yeah and leadership so you know
surgeons are used to the idea that no
one tells us what to do about the way we
do our operations got the new ship
captain the ship and I make the rules
the idea that there would be a
standardized way for any component of
the way that we do things the way we
communicate the way we plan the way we
work together as a team that's what the
checklist was really doing was saying
we're going to have a scripted way that
we discuss what the goals of the
operation are how we were going to get
it done and that was the culture change
to go from Cowboys to pit crews where we
would agree we would really be a pit
crew for the patient and that I'm
finding is true across many problems in
public health luckily as we've spread
our work into trying to figure out how
do you make change for childbirth or how
do you make change for people's
end-of-life care at the beginning of
life and end of life has been other
projects we've gotten involved in it's
been again this idea that there are
known ways that you can be more
effective and can we make it easy for
people to adopt those known ways
effectively and if we show that it works
then you kind of got to do it and that's
and that's a hard place to come to